neuf mois de recherches et d'essais
cliniques intense auront suffi pour
développer et autorisé le premier vaccin
contre la coved le sida quarante ans
plus tard on est toujours à la case
départ
il ya eu des bips dizaines des centaines
d'études sur des vaccins il n'y a jamais
eu vraiment de résultats intéressants
le docteur thomas a participé à l'énorme
effort de recherche pour vaincre le sida
ces patients le questionnant encore
régulièrement sur ce fameux vaccin qu'on
leur promet depuis si longtemps
ils se disent est ce que parce qu'on n'a
pas mis l'argent suffisamment est ce que
parce que ça touchait les populations
jeunes est vulnérable
il faut dire que virus du sida le vih
représentent un immense casse tête pour
les experts un vaccin
d'abord parce qu'il est toujours en
mutation en transformation dans
l'organisme de la personne infectée
c'est une cible mouvante très difficile
à atteindre pour le vaccin
si on a un vaccin contre une souche de
virus et que nous en ce cas ne
reconnaîtront plus nécessairement notre
réponse et min à ne reconnaître
nécessaire mais la forme mutante du
virus vih est également capable de
s'intégrer dans notre matériel génétique
et de se camoufler dans les cellules qui
les fait donc le virus peut rester
silencieux à la limite est aussitôt
qu'on arrête de te traiter par exemple
un patient le virus bord on vous renvoie
l'impression que le vaccin le plus
prometteur contre le sida affichait en
2009 un faible taux d'efficacité de 31%
ou ne l'a jamais mis à marcher et depuis
les recherches piétinent
évidemment il ya moins de pression à
développer des vaccins à l'heure
actuelle à cause des mythes scanner mais
faut pas oublier que quand même en 48
millions de personnes qui vivent avec le
vih c'est un effort collectif et
internationale qui aura permis de
développer un vaccin contre la coved
pourrait-on le répéter pour le vih
moi j'essaie de regarder de nos côtés
est-ce que cette recherche si d'arrivée
avec saint aussi efficace pour l'aco
ville peut apporter des lumières d
nouvelle pour la gauche heures d'un
vaccin encore contre le sida
ici norma grondin radio canada montréal